I'll start with .append and
.prepend, which you might remember from the Javascript Basics resume project.
These add children to an element.
So, if I select this DOM element of the firstArticleItem, I can call .append or
.prepend, and this new element will be added as a child to this one.
.append adds this new element as the last child of the selected item,
while .prepend adds this new element as the first child of the selected item.
When we test this code, we can see some cute puppies at the beginning of
Article 1 and at the end of Article 1.
But what if I wanted this element to have a sibling?
For that, I'll use .insertBefore or .insertAfter.
As you may guess, .insertBefore adds a sibling before the current element, and
.insertAfter adds a sibling after the current element.
You know what?
Why don't you give these a try?